Michael Cohen's attorney Lanny Davis is
with us from Washington
good morning landing good morning your
client said he made those payments to
the two women in coordination with and
at the direction of mr. Trump
implicating the president in a federal
crime was Michael Cohen have evidence of
that look this is one thing I'd like to
do this morning above all and which is
it's not about evidence it is definitive
indisputable that Donald Trump's lawyers
said in a letter to the special counsel
that President Trump directed the same
word that Michael cone used in court
yesterday under oath directed Michael
cone to make illegal payments it's not a
dispute it's not about credibility his
own lawyers used the word directed now
we lied on Air Force One when he said he
knew nothing about it and Rudy Giuliani
he said he can lie to the American
people and it's not a crime but his
lawyers are the witnesses against him
that he directed Michael cone there's no
dispute on that
well III appreciate that but I think you
can understand it's a pretty explosive
allegation to say that the president
directed him to do that and that's why
I'm asking about evidence because the
next question then becomes do you
believe the president is a
co-conspirator and that he could be
indicted first of all I do have to
respectfully disagree when you're a
lawyer state something that's evidence
that your own lawyer is saying that you
did something it's not a dispute his
lawyers wrote the special counsel and
said that he directed Michael Cohen to
make these payments and so the answer is
yes he committed a crime he should be
indicted if you were not president he
clearly would be indicted and jailed for
that crime whether he can be indicted as
president of course it was not yet
decided by the Supreme Court but Lanny
as you know lawyers can say one thing
one day and then they're paid to say the
opposite thing the next day and say it's
just a semantic debate which is why
evidence is so important in a courtroom
and in these kinds of political debates
so back to Nora's question yes what
lawyers may have said what they said the
game is now different what evidence
is there that your client has that the
president actually directed to him with
the purpose of fixing this with respect
to the election well actually with all
due respect when a lawyer makes an
admission of fact on behalf of a client
that is dispositive evidence it's not
disputable evidence and Rudy Giuliani
then repeated that statement as another
lawyer saying contradicting the lie that
President Trump made on Air Force One
when he said he didn't know anything
about it he said the president
reimbursed Michael Cohen so there is no
dispute that his lawyers have not taken
it back they wrote it to the special
counsel that President Trump committed a
crime by directing and why did he direct
because he didn't want his signature on
the check why because he was covering up
right before the election Manny why
didn't he do it himself
Manny last night you said that your
client Michael Cohen has evidence about
a conspiracy to collude and corrupt the
democracy system in the 2016 election
including computer crime hacking when
were your counsel speak with the special
counsel robert muller about this so i
was a little bit careful in the way I
phrased that I said that he had matters
that would be of interest to the special
counsel relating to pre knowledge of
computer hacking by Donald Trump which
if true if true would constitute
knowledge of a crime committed by a
foreign government in hacking our
computers which was part of the
indictment of 12 Russians that the
special counsel has already published so
my observation is that he can speak to
that and beyond that I can't go it will
have to you're saying Michael knew that
the present United States knew about
hacking during the campaign so I can't
go beyond saying that it's my
observation that this topic will be of
interest to the special counsel he has
statements that he can make along those
lines but I can't go beyond that
Lanny and the plea agreement it says one
or more members of the campaign knew
about payments is there another person
or persons who can corroborate what your
client is saying so that will be me
to be seen I do not personally know
those names Lani your client was hired
rudy giuliani notes and part of the his
job was to not tell the truth why should
anybody believe him well again I'm not
asking people to believe someone who is
confessed to crimes it's not about
Michael Cohen's credibility he did take
the responsibility and did confess to
those crimes lanny davis thank you so
much for joining us thanks for having me